bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono falli j
oggi iniziamo una nuova serie raga oggi
facciamo un esperimento comunque raga me
lo consigliava the veramente da
tantissimo tempo quindi raga oggi
facciamo questo esperimento faccio
questo episodio
se vi piace lo continuo se non vi piace
mi fermo qui non è un problema chi se ne
frega
facciamolo prendiamolo un po come
esperimento proviamo se va bene allora
lo continuo sennò pazienza germania del
nord travis residence che ci siamo ok
padre si perfetto a che bella
ambientazione fantastico papa se qui
dentro
ok up si fa il papa ai a quante volte ti
ho detto di non venire qui sotto accusa
papa ma ero troppo spaventata per
dormire da sola non preoccuparti non sei
mai sola tua madre sempre al tuo fianco
ti tiene sempre d'occhio aia ok ora per
favore torna a dormire si papa brava
bambina
ok andiamo a dormire così almeno no papà
domani domani andremo a visitare la sua
tomba insieme ok ora torno a dormire per
favore
arriverò anke io presto ok ci siamo se
n'è andato
sembrano le porte di amnesia ragazze che
cazzo di bus stop che cazzo no ma che
cazzo sto morendo qualcuno ed all aiuto
cos'è
oh mio dio ma che cazzo fai detto ma
questa è l'enigmista ma cazzo
conosco il segreto di papà è uno
scienziato ama le ricerche e sempre ci
sono il laboratorio di sotterranei
ho sempre sentito strani rumori da
quello venire a quel laboratorio ok
diventa inquietante la cosa animali e
urla di animali è ok messo non è l'unico
segreto che so quando io e mia madre non
erano in giro le due è la sua assistente
ma che schifo
cosa ci fa lì dentro un bio bio vabbè
può aspettare sì vieni maria anna maria
si chiamava vantaggio cuore si è già
storia un cazzo cioè che il taglio alle
braccia la gente prego dio sottore io
non mi farei abbracciare da uno così
comunque e non continua si abbracciano
va bene così sono a nella stanza da
letto fantastico mi sono svegliato
giorni a mezzanotte oggi è il giorno in
cui mamma è andata in paradiso non
riesco a dormire quando penso a mia
madre è ok ok ragazzi sono mi sto
muovendo io che è fantastico
un ritratto di mamma a sti cazzi del
balcone
cosa dovrei fare mamma e non so io
voglio bene papà ma è un pass travica la
mamma
lei mi spaventa a lei no lei si si non
in patria
lei è sempre mi guarda sempre con quegli
occhi la odio ma so che che ma so che a
papà piace se papa si sposasse un'altra
volta
credo che lei debba diventare la mia
nuova mamma ma c'è soltanto una mamma
nel mondo per me perché si è dovuta
andare via
ok la stanza è diventata fredda
improvvisamente sono spaventata dovrei
tornare a dormire ok invece vado fuori
ok ok dovrei andare a dormire non vado
fuori va bene faccio la brava bambina
ok ci dovrebbe buonanotte anche a tesi
fantastico dovremmo anche questo
inquietante che cazzo è stato un urlo
papa
ok qualcosa è successo devo andare a
controllare papa ok che cazzo ok ci sono
ragazzi è finito e filmato ci siamo è
bene non so quanto è durato ma è normale
che negli rpg
all'inizio ci sia un filmato inizia bene
ovvio mi sento strana o un brutto
presentimento anzi cioè ho tradotto di
merda va beh scusatemi anche se ogni
tanto sbaglio qualcosa ma abbiate
pazienza può succede cos'era questo
suono e quella voce
che cazzo è addio bambino di de grassi
che lasciano impronte ma non si vede che
cazzo oddio ci sono degli zombie scappa
va via da questa parte a chi è stato
vieni a questa parte ok andiamo andiamo
andiamo andiamo c'è qualcuno da gioco
penso dice se ti sta chiamando direi
ok ci siamo ai justin bieber aiutami
cazzo
chi sei tu da questa parte chi resta con
me ho detto oddio che cazzo è l'ho detto
resta con me ho detto da questa parte ma
vai dall'altra scappa
ok fan bene o cazzo siamo circondati
perfetta chi cazzo oddio il professor
layton che cazzo ci fa maraga che sta
succedendo di trasferire i primi achara
chi sei tu
ora non s ora no ora non essere
aggressiva sono soltanto un uomo
d'affari perché ci dovrebbero essere dei
mostri come quelli beh è una maledizione
quelli che hai visto sono i corpi che
tuo padre
utilizzava come soggetti per i suoi
testi sono ritornati di certo per
prendersi la vendetta su tuo padre ok
cosa
mio padre in pericolo devo andare a
salvarlo eppure tu desideri ancora
salvarlo
evidentemente sì ok forse lei non riesce
ancora a capire il loro dolore
guarda non lo so però sei un pelato che
non so che cazzo ci fa in una stanza di
una bambina ma poi è sempre stato
gentile con me ed è l'unico papa che ho
e ci mancherebbe
devo andare a salvare papa ok andiamo ci
siamo ora cos'è a club un corvo che
cazzo ci fa un corvo qui
cos'è al salvataggio che figo ok a
fantasy ok ragazzi siamo finalmente
posso muovermi libero quindi da adesso
in avanti inizia il vero gioco direi di
andare avanti
è questo attico fantastico c'è lattico
ok c'è un'altra gemma la sulla vedo alla
scala manca una parte ok fantastico devo
trovare l'altra parte della scala che
non c è come si apre inventario tra
annuncerò l'inventario forse non mi
ricordo va bene un'importanza lucio
abbiamo nulla e abbiamo salvato si
stanza da letto qua non ci sono entrato
prima è una bambola quella cazzo non è
una bambola da me la dà mela indietro da
mia figlia ok vai via via via via via
via
ok che cazzo è successo mi scusi cazzo
non c'è più luccica cos'è sta roba
ho trovato la chiave degli archivi
fantastico c'è anche una cassaforte tra
l'altro è chiusa vabbè lo vedo e non so
il codice per aprirla a ok c'è un codice
devo trovare il codice per aprirla vabbè
ma intanto andrò più avanti ok ho paura
di andare avanti o mio dio di sotto non
ci vado di sicuro perché a questa la
chiave degli archivi fantastico
c'è un altro corpo bene è fantastico
salvato c'è un'altra porta di giu ok
devo a casa ci sono i libri a terra
devo trovare qualcosa cosa cos'è ho
trovato dei libri sugli esperimenti di
papa c'è qualcosa di bloccato qui ho
trovato un codice a deve essere quello
della casa forte di prima
buongiorno mamma mamma fa male aiutatemi
aiutatemi oggi e scappa
che cazzo è dio papa no non mi dire che
odio voglio andare a casa voglio andare
voglio vedere mamma non preoccuparti ti
porterò la lei una volta che tutti che
sarà tutto finito
no voglio andare adesso mamma mamma non
avere fretta tutto quanto andrà bene ok
voglio soltanto che tu testi questa
medicina potrebbe far male un pochettino
ma non ma non troppo presto ti sentirai
sollevata no mamma
oddio ma che brutta fermati ok
sì cazzo non voglio sentire tutto questo
ma che cosa uscente no no ma che è
brutto perché come secondo
ma no macché cei ha tirato un cazzotto
poverina mamma no è una cosa orribile
ragazze ma mio dio
vabbè che cazzo è sta roba
c'è qualcuno che striscia beh è infatti
andato qui sotto che cazzo c'è una gemma
ho trovato un posto segreto è bene c'era
qualcuno che strisciava non voglio
sapere chi era
devo andare avanti stanza delle bambole
fantastico bella c'è un'altra io trovo
gemme ovunque
secondo me io ho il presentimento che
queste si muovano e così dettagliata
sembra apparentemente sembra una bambola
ok c'è qualcosa qui dietro cazzo ci sono
due bambole nascoste queste bambole
hanno sorriso spaventoso ok bene
l'utilità di tutto questo qual è non lo
so usciamo però devo andare a trovare se
riesco a trovare il sotterraneo per
raggiungere mio padre magari questa
chiusa sindaco vista allora dobbiamo
andare lì sotto se non ci sono andata
una donna elisa oddio ci sono gli zombie
chi cazzo sono questi
entriamo da qualche parte chi cazzo sono
questi sono gli zombie prima merda via
oddio mi sono stuprando entra ok bene ci
sono zombie ovunque e c'è del sangue
ovunque cazzo che è fantastico stanza
ricette sono c'è di nuovo il corvo raga
devo capire un attimo dov'è
cos'è che è successo che hai visto credo
di aver sentito qualcuno
l'orologio se stoppato a mezzanotte ok
fantastico si è mosso il quadro ok c'è
si è mosso il quasi è mossa la monna
lisa
c'è un cassetto forse non c'è nulla
sto cercando di evitare di avvicinarvi
non si nota vero
ok mi scusi il ritratto di una splendida
donna che cazzo è ovvio
cos'è mi stuprano premi z sempre modesta
mai togliti di mezzo tutto stronzo
[Musica]
ma mio zio che cosa brutta togliti chi
cazzo sei ok vice k cos'era quella roba
o mio dio c'è ma ragazzo gioca tiro di
colpi di scena
cazzo vi siete dovuti sorbire il filmato
iniziale ma da adesso in avanti
tenetevi pronti mio dio al bagno
c'è una roba che luci mi scusi mi scusi
se l'è calpesta la testa non è mia
intenzione ok c'è qualcosa che luccica
c'è la chiave della chiave della
caffetteria e normale che qualcuno è
uscito da una vasca di sangue cazzo ok
buongiorno c'è uno che è uscita dalla
vasca di prima il suo amico ma quella
non era una bambola tra l'altro era una
delle bambole che cos'era quella bambola
che si muoveva non lo so faceva parte la
maledizione che quella sta diventando
inquietante raga è ok
cazzo ci sono gli zombie apriti apriti
cielo fattaci di nuovo il corvo allora
ragazzi una sedia che caduta
sì non c'è nulla che è fantastico devo
trovare il punto dove dove scendere nei
sotterranei che c'è un cane
c'è un cane zombie e anche penombra c'e
di tutto il suo gioco cazzo c'è il
tappeto che e mezzo ha perse con dove
c'è qualcosa di sotto devo correre prima
che il cane se ne accorga vai vai vai
c'era una botola veramente
oddio è il cane non sia per niente
accorto di me forse se riesco a fare ma
stare molto tranquillo non se ne accorge
ho preso dell'olio si bene devo prendere
ok una gemma c'è di tutto dovrebbe
starci lontano sia con cordova bene
andiamo giù dovrebbero essere questi i
sotterranei se non sbaglio aic non posso
andare qui sotto è troppo buio mi serve
allora raga l'olio cielo mi serve una
lanterna soltanto che non ciò la
lanterna cioè come cazzo faccia ma si
può aprire inventare in sto gioco
credo di no force sia si può aprire
l'inventario che cazzo dico a c'è mi
sono dimenticato che c'è il codice cazzo
chan è ok vi stanno aggredendo di colpo
va bene e mi stanno aggredendo anche gli
zombie o mio dio ok allora piano
andiamo ad aprire quella cassaforte di
prima spero di trovarci la lanterna così
a me non riesco ad andare di sotto
non so il codice magari questa nota
potrebbe darmi in aiuto si aspetta che
lo vedo come cazzo si visualizza i
barili nel primo piano nella sala est i
candelieri nella sala dell'entrata le
bambole nella stanza delle bambole e
dipinti nella stanza della reception
si vede che ci sono scritti dei numeri
in giro allora i barili nella stanza al
primo piano e allora andiamo
devo sì ho capito allora mi serve carta
e penna perché non me li ricorderò mai
il cazzo
allora i barili barili bari rivali lì ci
sono gli zombie cazzo come faccio
devo forse che aveva detto questi non
sono questi come cazzo faccio forse devo
andare in questa porta si ok
ecco infatti ci sono sì che cazzo mi
rappresentano sì cosa dovrei fare qui
allora c'è un corpo e basta non c'è
nulla si è pieno di bari lo vedo che
piero di parità non ci sono numeri
cos'è quello mio dio che il calcio
estero
oddio vai via scappa cos'è non lo so non
lo voglio sapere mai pia bene fantastico
e c'è una porta qui che chiusa ok devo
trovare dei numeri qui ma non so come
faccio a devo contarli forse 1234567 ok
primo numero 7 credo allora barili nella
prima stanza nella stanza del primo
piano a destra ok sono sette candelieri
nell'entrata ok i candelieri ok va bene
nell'entrata dovrebbe essere questa che
cannes sono 41 le altre 4 sono quelli
cazzola che le scale verda striscia
ovunque sta a fare bene e siamo quanti
erano 474 le bambole nella stanza delle
bambole ok tutte o mio dio ma erano 200
vabbè andiamo comunque a vedere tanto
quelle sono comunque ragazza e
divertente da fare
devo le bambole aree bambole russe nella
stanza delle bambole ok allora sono 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 allora 7 questa conta cazzo
non lo so
vabbè 12345678 ma al massimo conto 9 se
quella con quella in alto a sinistra
contava beh ora sono 7 49 ei dipinti
della stanza della reception ok e dove
cazzo ecco mi pare che fosse qui sotto
ma non ne sono sicuro mi stava prendendo
questa norma è questa cazzo non me lo
ricordo a si è questo e questo e questo
ok dov'è 12 sono che i fan tra l'altro
qui dentro c'è ancora qualcuno movie the
painting si ok posso entrare lì dentro
veramente io non ci tengo ad entrarci
sinceramente pro entriamo c'è un cortile
c'è un buco nel cestino che è fatta a
posso uscire anche in cortile che figo
c'è un'altra gemma cioè sto trovando
tutte le gemme del del gioco
praticamente lo sto completando al
massimo posso usare serve qui l'acqua è
così chiara e limpida usare set non tra
i pokémon mi dispiace sono due dipinti
comunque è anzi erano due perché uno e
facciamo uno e mezzo va vabbè comunque
74 92 74 82 anzi 92
vabbè adesso proviamo comunque non ne
sono sicuro
in teoria dovrebbe essere 74 82 e spero
di trovarci la lanterna almeno quello
speriamo che funzioni allora 74 82
ok ce l'ho fatta è incredibile non ci
posso credere al primo tentativo ok
profuma della mamma
ok c'è una lampada qui dentro se ce l'ho
fatta
magari potrebbe essere utile la prendo
ok prendo soltanto questa mamma
fantastico la lampada cielo
ciò anche l'olio e che cazzo è caduto
cos'è questo questo è il profumo di
mamma flashback ok ci siamo allora
questi c'è la mamma che si profuma cosa
è sempre lavoro più maria ok penso
voglia dire l'ovvio comunque
dottore si perché lasci la porta
socchiusa a papa ai a sei qui tuo padre
non ti ha sempre detto di non scendere
nei sotterranei
oh cazzo cazzo non dovrebbe farlo lo
sapevo mi sta tradendo con quella non
posso crederci una ragazza presa per la
strada non lo perdonerò mai
ok hai fatto un disastro dover chiudere
la porta
no perché va dai poveri e la perché mi
trovati già tela la protagonista
maledizione a incazzata forte penso
ebbene che cosa quella stupida cosa
cos'è
ma no cos'è che ha lanciato il profumo
ma non fosse un anello ma poverino ad
iron perché mi drammatizzate la bambina
va bene è una cosa triste cioè mamma è
sempre stata così fantastica ma sembrava
così diversa quella volta
ok aveva lanciato veramente profumo e
non si è rotto mica che miracolo preso
con i mama ok fantastico cioè non è
l'inventario e non so che cosa me ne
possa fare del profumo ah beh non
importa
apro sempre l'armadio perché ho sempre
paura di trovarci qualcuno ma io la pro
sono un genio dove domandare 18 vani
sotterranei ragazzi siamo
stiamo per arrivare alla stanza del
padre
ok ci dovremmo essere in teoria
fantastico tra l'altro raga il gameplay
appunto di asi e buio giustamente devo
tirarla fuori la pace l'ho già perfetto
non c'era bisogno
raga siamo nel sotterraneo
ci sono dei barili sì una fila di barili
c'è un buco nel muro che devo fare
non posso entrarci qui dentro troppo
piccolo sì ci credo è chiusa che cazzo
ci devo fare allora qui dentro ci
mettono l'olio non penso che serva
qualcosa allora cosa devo fare
il cane serve a qualcosa tipo sembra
vicino no no mi fa ancora entrare nella
porta principale oddio chi cazzo è c'è
un morto sul davanzale buongiorno non si
muove sarà meglio farmi salvare tra si è
mosso ok bene salvo prima che vi stupri
fantastico cioè ha lasciato una gemma se
mi avvicino mi ammazzi devo prendere mi
scusi se la calpesta ok ho preso la
gemma me ne vado ok ragazzo non tornato
nella mia stanza è quel tipo se n'è
andato sarà meglio c'è anche il coniglio
qui ancora vivo non sarei portato via
prendi palla di neve se cosa cosa vuol
dire a lo porto dietro
andiamo a salvare papa insieme ok hai
preso poi la rideva dai l'ho preso
proprio c'è ma mi porto un coniglio nel
nello zaino idea o mio dio lampo di
genio cazzo
devo no infatti ho sbagliato stanza devo
andare 18 lampo di genio assurdo ok raga
non so se funziona ma dovrebbe in teoria
aspettate la sicurezza fatemi salvare
prima
ok
ci prova non sono sicuro ma ci provo vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
ok c'è un buco nel muro proviamo ecco
magari palle di neve passarci se vai
palla c'è un buco
sì infatti di mettere la palla però sono
come cazzo fa a sottomettere io ok vai
vai palla di neve ci aprì fare aprile a
sono palla di neve che figo sono
diventato un coniglio devo aprire la
porta tipo si se riesco a sbloccarla
che bello tutto buio qui dentro cosa ci
cos'è sta roba
ho trovato dell'olio della lanterna
fantastico e poi c'è un cazzo
che devo fare che me ne faccio di sodio
no quella di neve
lui si è andato cazzo si è spenta la
luce merda merda merda e l'olio
dell'interno ha preso palla di neve
perché non funziona per favore salve
cazzo c'è qualcuno dietro di me
evidentemente sì magari lo soltanto
immaginato no c'era qualcuno cosa devo
fare
merda via da lì ok vado vado via
me ne vado preferisco ok raga direi che
posso andare o cazzo cos'è bene dei
invece c'è scritto qualcosa penso in
tedesco cioè vabbè ci sono delle
impronte sul muro mio zio
raga i sotterranei in teoria dovrebbero
essere qui sotto
salvo ho già salvato sì direi che posso
concludere qui l'episodio ovviamente gli
episodi di matt father durano di più dei
miei video normali perché essendo un rpg
cioè non è una roba c'è nel senso non è
pesante non urla ogni 4 secondi anche se
comunque per essere pg è più pesante di
quanto mi immaginassi comunque va beh
direi che posso concludere video qui
ricordatevi che questo è un esperimento
ovvero se vi piace lo continuo se non vi
piacciono lo continuo a non importa
fatevi soltanto sapere se vi dove è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione e
non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video bei
ragazzi